so the question becomes surveillant
mentally well changes in attention
multitasking the sense of immediate
access to external information not their
own external information will that
change the formation of what I'm talking
about when I say deep reading well in an
essence short-circuit us with
short-circuit our next generation so the
deep reading brain for you
requires that you allocate time requires
that you use that neuronal workspace
when you read and I'm not talking about
all the time all of us when we do email
we are absolutely with course we have to
scan it but the reality is there's much
reading that we are bleeding into with
that same mode of reading so on the one
hand I'm worried about adults not
allocating what they could but more
importantly it takes years of formation
for for kids to develop all of those
deep reading processes this is not this
is this is not casual this is the
essence of critical thinking my
colleague at MIT sherry Turkle said this
we transgressed not because we try to
build anew but because we do not allow
ourselves to consider what it disrupts
or diminishes that's really the point
that's why I dare to come into a
technology-driven cafe and say
outrageous things I need to be sure we
all have a kind of cerebral pause to
think about are we changing will our
children change what will be lost what
will be disrupted
but I am NOT saying that we can go back
I am this is no binary message we cannot
go back but I also suggest that we
should not simply lurch forward to the
next new thing the next new thing but
rather
ask the question what must we preserve
that is essential and what must we
acquire to gain what is necessary for
the 21st century child
Patricia Greenfield a colleague at UCLA
said something that is just so simple
and so right
no one medium can do everything every
medium has its costs and weaknesses
every meaty developed some cognitive
skills at the expense of others
although the digital media may develop
impressive visual intelligence I would
say far more than that the cost seems to
be deep processing mindful knowledge
acquisition inductive analysis critical
thinking and reflection
[Music]